oui bon bien nous allons terminer dans
la bonne humeur avec cabu qui nous
propose tentons accroc c'est à dire quoi
ton accroc vous savez on parle des
drogués ou des qui sont accros c'est à
dire ils peuvent plus se détacher 2
alors je pense qu'ils je pense qu'il va
se représenter effectivement parce qu'
il ne peut pas faire autrement à hilla
il sera en manquant autrement de pouvoir
de pouvoir original vous l'aimez bien
quand même
j'aime bien le dessiner j'aime bien
dessiner mais non j'ai aucune et on
parlait de ça l'autre jour avec un autre
dessinateur des canards kerleroux lui
anna tendresse pour déménager c'est vrai
j'ai aucune tendresse pour un homme
politique
aucun parce que je suis un écolo et que
à part les écolos je trouve que ils ont
tous tort ils ont tous tort je la dis
sur notre bonjour moi je vous le dit au
dessus de formule 1 on va voir des
dessins par exemple la voilà la porte
avec mitterrand 80 88 qui arrive
voilà ça c'est donc ces promos ni
thouars ça c'est ça râle voilà allons-y
tonton une bête de télé voilà on va on
va passer d'autres tout ça ce sont des
dessins récents 1
ah oui oui tout ça ce sont des dessins
que vous avez fait pour le processeur
album allons-y choix et qu'on présente
des idées voilà alors ça ça c'est une
reprise de la fiche de la fiche de rpr
pour les élections mais ça arrive
il ya donc eu des graines formidable
après s'il vous plaît des dessins voilà
ça c'est sûr rockhal c'était le rêve
allons rentrer la grande école c'est pas
encore pour cette fois je pense je crois
mais vous aimez vous aimez tous les
dessiner ou ça vous avez beaucoup parce
que bar par exemple il est très dur pile
amaigri alors il en béton oui oui à
l'embêter will change leur a bien voilà
sur svindal a fallu évidemment
greenpeace si josi est un bateau qui l'a
fait à lagord exactement parce que c'est
ça bon à chaque fois on vote pour le
moins pire mais même le moins pire
il a fait un great enfin il a il a
couvert greenpeace quand même quoi vous
voterez non non non je ne veux je veux
très bien cette fois non je vais il ya
un candidat écolo ah oui je me ferai
peut-être au premier où il est candidat
écolo alors oui c'est ça il ferait de
lavit est d'ailleurs on le voit pas
personne ne l'invité politique de
abonnez vous demandez lui c'est vrai
c'est pas tout mais pas à ce point non
mais le pen quatre fois et est un non
sens inverse
non mais je sais pas c'est pas vos
crayons c'est bien mais oui oui oui
n'ont pas fait quelque chose
oui le candidat écolo maintenant pour le
journal on fera quelque chose mais je
lui ai déjà dit bien alors vous aviez
publié avant un autre le mois précédent
alors sur quelqu'un alors que vous
détestez alors là c'est pas ben oui
alors c'est le gros blond avec sa
chemise noire évidemment si vous pouvez
montrer le dos de couverture on
comprendra voilà le bandeau de
couverture comme ça mais d'autres
couvercle bordeaux a glissé bandeau a
glissé voilà leur manque alors là c'est
il a bon hein
alors là vous taper fort hein parce que
le mitterrand à côté c'est gentil c'est
sympathique accueil sympathique lui chez
albin michel voilà eh bien les dessins
de cabu mais c'est un très grand
dessinateur c'est un oui il ya qu' il
n'y a que vous qui fait l'unanimité ne
soit pas tombé
vous croyez oui aucun des eaux de peut
faire du taf et d'unité est ce que vous
demande d'y céder les écolos font
l'unanimité c'est bien
voilà merci nous avons à rejouer avec au
dessin dans toutes les missions quelques
ouvrages pour terminer je